maintenant chips juste après la jetée
type c merci ça fait plaisir les gens
qui agissent victime chips au hockey
hockey à l'aise à l'oeil cette vague
n'est pas de moi c'est sur ce score à
l'aide de tiger cela valide sarek ça va
très très bien
alors apparaître matin j'étais lui
plusieurs sujets il y en a un qui allait
partir mais intéressé way est pour toi
cela en particulier lors pourquoi c'est
une question qui dépose et c'était
coïncidence vrai parce que en fait cyrus
m'a appelé et un groupe vraiment une
liste de tous et dans cette liste il ya
eu un débat que j'ai eu avec des potes
genre deux joueurs enfin non c'était pas
vraiment débat ces tours s'était posé la
question on s'était marié dessus on
s'était dit avant ce serait marrant si
on allait plus besoin de manger
donc c'est sale et c'était juste est-ce
que c'était juste manger parce que c'est
une question qui arrivait souvent dans
les commentaires
est-ce que c'était juste manger où
c'était aussi leur à boire c'était plus
manger juste manger en bord de l'eau on
peut voir de l'eau ouais voilà ça l on a
besoin de boire de l'eau c'est notre
corps voit quand même quand même pas
enlever la nation sont bloqués à
benghazi
on m'interdit de présenter parce que je
pense que tout le monde connaît mais on
sait jamais peut-être des gens qui
connaissent pas je te laisse le faire
c'est plate à free c'est de la frite
sl être cela s'inscrit exactement
beaucoup de mots nîmes c'est sur youtube
depuis un bail de ce que je fais c'est
de l'analyse
deux clips de musique et maintenant tu
détruis un peu plus à l'est aussi
genre un docu sur le rap tout à fait il
inquiet on peut lire coureux donc
vachement cool j'ai bien présente et pas
mais que c'est parfait bonifacio
enfin m en fait il fait des vidéos la
philosophie sur des débats ouverts comme
la ce qu'on va faire supporter à temps
vraiment c'est super intéressant à une
vision des choses et et à regarder comme
ça tranquillement pour pour s'évader
c'est vraiment un réel plaisir
s'ils veulent aussi sur ce match à turin
compte beaucoup sa vie vraiment cédé
story très très très très longue s'est
calmé un peu calmé t'imagines si ya pas
encore de génériques mais ça arrive tu
connais principe liesse si on avait plus
besoin de manger ça résoudrait de
nombreux problèmes écologiques
on n'aurait pas besoin de faire des
élevages immense de bétail et autres
animaux donc moins de vaches qui
émettrait de méthane les vaches pourrait
disparaître si l'homme ne les utilisent
plus et qu'elles sont inadaptées un
milieu naturel
d'un autre côté il ya de nombreux
métiers qui risquerait de disparaître
éleveurs agriculteurs restaurateurs qui
signait mais qui ne serait plus utile à
la société
dans ta maison ouais mais du coup
suivant notre nouveau mode de prise
d'énergie il y aurait de nouveaux
métiers
oui oui mais ce sont des métiers genre
actuelle on parlait du fait qu'on
imagine on prend par le soleil mon
énergie
il y aurait des mecs réflecteurs
professionnels panneaux géants renvoie
le soleil multichoix le réflecteur cet
après midi ça va mieux leurs frais jeu
ça fait du bien parce que le temps tu
déconnes métier que en suède thé pendant
l'hiver mais qu'ils ont du soleil entre
11h et 15h tu as c'est vraiment des mini
plage
ok et
c'est pas des plages oui la jeune relève
beaucoup de sable et en gros donc le
reste du temps il fait nuit et du coup
ça pèse grave sur le moral de tout le
monde tout le monde à moins de vitamines
d et c'est un machin et du coup ils vont
dans des scénarios et genre y en a qui
ont des lampes des lampes solaires chez
eux et tous machin ce nécessaire quoi
donc ça sera un business qui serait
beaucoup plus développée là je pense
nommé vous à sare maîtriseront en fin de
chaque petit élément comme ça notre camp
qui serait énergétique ça remet en cause
toute ta façon de fonctionner puisque
genre s'écrirait des nouvelles maladies
je le fait naître mon moi exposés ça
créerait des six il y aurait des métiers
à y opposer
oui mais voilà à dire et il y aura
d'autres métiers les des choses
fantastiques sur le son métier ont tous
sauté quoi avec la robotisation falloir
revoir le système en randonnée donc les
technologies mais voilà il ya un moment
donné à l'enneigement artificiel
j'entends de réfléchir aussi aurait pas
un truc qui ferait qu'on utiliserait les
animaux pour poteau balayé le ch vos
fenêtres foot c'est des activités avec
des animaux prévoient même via le cuir
mais que les fourrures en face au genre
de trucs
en fait je vous dis que ça créerait
place au problème existait rien tara
franchement en vrai le même le cuir tout
ça et tout c'est rien par rapport à
l'oeil l'industrie agroalimentaire corps
c'est que dalle d'un budget dérisoire
que celui de voix jeudi minimes quatre
fois que je cours des minimes par jour
sont n'ai plus besoin de manger on se
recentrerait sur un autre besoin comme
dormir ou la gastronomie et laisserait
place à la dodo logis et on va aider des
restes d'os d'oran mexicain même chinois
d'un bien différemment la respire au
logis avec les restaurants ou peut
respirer des odeurs du chef ou la
sexologie
papa tu dis que c'est moi qui vais loi
mais c'est vrai le mec ou la meuf c'est
mathieu mathieu m
c'est mathieu c'est mathieu et ben ouais
voilà les en fait c'est pas faux mais
alors ça fait penser à un truc
[ __ ] [ __ ] je parle c'est un truc ça
s'appelle mais je sais plus comment ça
s'appelle exactement le nom
c'est un mouvement qui existe qui lui et
qui existe vraiment jaya des maquettes
des établissements ok je partais sa
restaurant du coup mais le thème des
résidents eux ou en gros il considère
qu' on n'a pas besoin de bouffe vraiment
et donc du coup c'est se nourrissent la
lettre mexes et nice n'ont pas le choix
ils peuvent pas ça que c'est tous des
menteurs ils rentrent chez sydbank et
après ils vous font sauter bourse à
terre l'air de paris [ __ ] je vous
salue non mais attends je vais vous dire
d'être beaucoup là je l'aï pas saisie de
l'inédit parfois appelée respirianisme
prades isme c'est le fait pour une
personne de vivre sans se nourrir
parfois sans boire et cela sur de
longues périodes pouvant concerner une
partie non négligeable de sa vie les cas
décrits sont souvent légendaires ou
concomitant d'un contexte religieux
voire mystique ou sectaire la
possibilité de l'inédit et contraire aux
connaissances de la physiologie humaine
tu m'étonnes les rares cas cliniquement
suivi sont entachés de bié
observationnelles et de soupçons de
charlatanisme l'extrémisme l'extrémisme
ce comportement est dénoncé comme cause
de sous-nutrition parfois mortelles on
parle aussi de il ya un gars qui a
étudié la pratique du seul gaming c'est
se nourrir de la lumière du soleil en
observant celui ci aux premières heures
du jour
au crépuscule s'appelle la grève de la
faim voilà c'est un peu ça a ajouté
l'amptp aux langues qu'ils font mais
après le jeune hacker le vertueux tu
vois genre le fait de jeûner c'est à
quelques vertus et cetera
si tu fais avec modération machin est
rouge vous laissera creuser le truc tu
vois comme cette docte enfin 9 passes a
toujours bien les respectifs
ouais bah peut-être que j'aurai alors
voilà un certain moment ça passe
tu sais que quand j'étais au népal a
dans les dix jours on nous force est
enfin nous remplissent et jamais notre
notre estomac est en fait le but c'était
connect toujours faim trois genres en
bouffer à 6 heures du matin à midi et
ensuite juste jusqu'au lendemain on
avait juste une banane et un peu de
pommes et jean-claude y en a un c'est
mon quotidien de sa jauge à 6 heures
mais j'espère que tu mangeais plus que
deux matchs parce que et en gros le but
c'était de maintenir l'estomac au max h
3 87%
comme tout enfin comme tout il ya du bon
et il ya du bon à prendre dans un peu
tous tu vois mais mollo les extrémistes
quoi manger un petit peu c'est dangereux
les carences les en plus les carences un
truc que tu vois pas venir il nous faut
que ça tombe dessus
puis on est parti dans un truc d'auxi
sait jamais si vous n'avez plus besoin
de manger les aliments manufacturés les
frites n'existerait donc pas du coup
c'est de l'afrique dans le passé pseudo
ça me rendrait que plus crédible c'est
qu'il aime des bas je m'appelais les
frites et autres familles s'effrite et
ferrite et je m'appellerai quand même ça
sauf que les gens ne seraient pas ce que
cette vie dure et rohff c kom nov
drogba c'est un autre vip
l'aseb l'afrique ne serait pas fiable à
frites non sinon il ya quelqu'un qui
disait les frais disparaîtrait ipsen
sinon il ya un gars qui gisent
d'empêcher patrick vraiment bien gars
qui dit sinon si on n'a plus besoin de
manger c'est de la frime ça m'avait pas
simple à trith n'ont vraiment rien n'a
beaucoup beaucoup benoît elle achetant
les lieux juste 3 mayrand vrais jeux
para commentaires sur combien c'était il
y avait cette vanne [ __ ] du coin quand
je vois le temps allaitantes
oui quand il fait bon en même temps on
doit parler de manger avec seb l'afrique
mais moi je t'ai déjà fait
du coup est ce qui met à regarder avec
beaucoup de peine oui souvent souvent je
vous dis encore là j'imagine et des
bananes
oui et les fruits oui je suis quand même
là tu as besoin
vous êtes obligé monsieur sinon vous
mourrez le sujet mais je respecte parce
que j'ai encore envie de parler
d'éthique et la liste ça me perturbe qu
est-ce qu il n'y a pas un moment où ton
corps est dit 'stop achat' si le lycée
la mort nous apprennent la mort mais
elle ne tombe pas dans les pommes oh oh
allez je vide à la question tu m'a
soufflé un like va souffler voilà c'est
cadeau alors grosse perte des
interactions sociales et du martyre du
noyau familial
on ne se retrouve plus autour du repas
autour d'autres choses mais quoi
question ouverte
carrément j'ai pensé tout à l'heure un
plus sans vouloir faire le mec sur gold
de dolo j ai donc que me disait gérard
maduel je crois déjà rentrés non mais
bon conte frais d'essence de d'audience
voici les cinq minutes c'est pas un
perso si la loi est diponible échanges
s'est pas libéré comment garder toute la
médiane entre et des jeux quoi ouais
ouais de toute société
mais est-ce qu'on aurait ce truc ce
moment de discussions sans la bouffe je
suis pas sûr il ya les sorties en
famille il ya les patients en vrai tu
vois les gens quotidiennement dont il
s'en sert il s'agira de la bouffe c'est
vraiment ce moment social on partage un
truc en fait c'est la bouffe qui nous
force à nous réunir en plein boom mais
je n'ai pas besoin de bouffer tout tu te
mettrai aussi avec tes parents pendant
une heure à table à discuter je passe
sur nos lancements web photos du palais
mais jean continuellement bas aussi il
s'offre un sas ferais tu vois mais bon
chacun vous aurez des choses meilleures
à faire quoi
oui je pense qu'on perd à ce moment très
triste
gr encore une fois ça dépend de comment
on prendra notre énergie tu vois si
c'était au tour on voit le faire des
bains solaire ensemble pauvres autour
d'eux
la boule bleue solaire de salon et qui
retrouve alors dévoue solaire de salon
tu vois en fait
en fait c'est quoi j'entends me rends
compte que ça dépendra aussi de la
manière dont avait claqué en propre
energy genre là c'est de la bouffe la
bouffe c'est un truc qui est vachement
pratique à plusieurs fabricants tu
cuisines un truc voilà le temps de
cuisiner
bah si je rajoute une personne aux deux
personnes trois personnes nous ne savons
pas beaucoup plus de temps hésingue
afghanistan le monde tu vois donc ça
on était en étant des vingt-sept était
tournée mais aussi ouais moi je te
disais ouais je t'ai cammas et je te
disais que en gros la bouffe aussi la
manière dont on va te faire la bouffe
etc
c'est fait pour qu'on soit plusieurs tu
as prince à privilégie le fait d'être
plusieurs tubes pour cela le solaire de
tramway alors que si on avait un autre
moyen de prendre de l'énergie qui était
beaucoup plus individualiste et
peut-être que même tout notre souci
était donc tu vois on sait moins tourné
vers la famille c'est en fait tu vois
genre la famille c'est aussi parce qu'on
a besoin comme nous risquons écosse n'a
besoin que nos parents nous nourrissent
ce sont des plus besoin de ça et qu'on
pouvait être indépendant en direct ont
joué tous les rapports qu'on a tous les
rapports en fait [ __ ] ça changerait de
vraiment tout de manière de voir la
société
pourquoi on se dirait pas autour d'auch
autour de boissons mais parce que j'ai
pas besoin de toi pour avoir de l'eau
alors que tu as à leurs cuisines et
bains au début tu sais quand tes gosses
puissent pas cuisiner prendre de l'eau
tu peux le prendre pour un dieu c'est
votre meilleur souvenir de même pas de
cuisine ouais ce que ça s'est amélioré
il y aurait toutes les raisons de se
battre et grâce à pascal et cuisine
c'est moi ou il se change de tous et
schmitt et c'est seulement schmitt et
cuisine c'est moi wayne drake split au
fait qu'un tiers des chemises alors
voilà il nous aurons atteint sélection
génétique et à un jour peut-être une
cuisine un élève très simple
elle est vrai qu'elle était potes au jeu
les passer au four direct force à la
cathédrale
ouais un groupe paul voilà beaucoup de
poids lourds dans la crainte et la
tuberie la blague des p'tits déj n'ont
pas de bol c'est celle de la frite me
retrouver sur sa chaîne du niveau
culturel vous pourrez pu découvrir un
pays par cette nourriture
bah oui je n'achète pas d'accord parce
qu'on y est et on sait pas parce qu'on a
plus besoin qu'on voudrait plus on
pourrait avoir ce côté un peu culturel
de la bouffe peut-être la boucle serait
un art
finalement voilà c'est exactement ça
serait donc il me semblerait en fait
c'est beaucoup plus simple que ça l'est
maintenant ça l'est déjà beaucoup
oui en gastronomie tout ça voilà mais je
pense ça serait que ça en fait oui mais
c'est gratuit et ça par contre sur le
6ème l'allemagne découvrir un pays
ouais enfin c'est valable parce que
jusqu'à ma musique tu as la musique on
ne va pas besoin oui c'est juste
appréciable tu vois et je pense que la
bouffe c'est ce qu'on disait au début
avec le cinéma et tout s'est tu peux
découvrir aussi des pays par leur
culture cinématographique toi jean
bollywood sap a répondu oui c'est vrai
ça et donc je suis pas d'accord avec ça
pour le coup mais économiquement la
bouffe serait plus cher si c'est un
accès personnel à au jeu
j'ai mon papa est en effet beaucoup plus
cher à la bouffe ta pas franchement ce
n'est pas moi qui fais ouais mais je
fais ça c'est ma vie en train de faire
ça ça de débattent de trucs métier que
moi c'est ce qui l'a fait kiffer la file
aux siens c'est que l'envolée fin de
soirée où t'es là et tu poses des
questions machin est tout à fait lisa le
début de la file autres mais en fait je
suis voilà moi je passe un fond très
cool et plus tu remercies de méditer sur
cette chaîne d'une très confortable mais
je t'en prie je t'en prie je t'en prie
parce que j'avais fait un bisou fois la
prochaine question à la question à
laquelle vous devez répondre
la voilà une question spécial noël
tu imagines si le père noël existe est
avec le dr nordmann qui a déjà fait une
vidéo sur le sujet pour la question je
suis pas je suis pas du tout d'accord
en fait il a pas vu un gars comme ça
plus tard la gueule et ben quoi on
connaît pas la question mais sachez que
que c'est pas possible vu que tout le
monde tous les tous les hommes et une
[ __ ]
voilà je dis là dessus merci beaucoup
merci à tout le monde d'avoir participé
à poser des questions et c'est
l'équipage ils s'y sont vachement
différent parce que je sais que par le
dernier tu vois j'ai eu autant personnes
qui m'ont ils dit ouais c'est mon
préféré que vaut tant de personnes qui
ont dit ouais c'est celui que j'ai moins
aimé tout cas ça dépend de vous ça
dépend de l'inviter ça dépend de la
question enfin c'est donc plein de trucs
donc un axe ont beaucoup plus qui vont
être beaucoup plus sur des faits y perd
scientifiques et aux mecs qui vont être
beaucoup plus sur la rigolade et
maintenant est beaucoup plus sûr de
l'imagination et aux enfants et c'est ça
qui est effectif
en ce moment je m'excuse pour les gens
qui voulaient voir me sens pousser
voilà c'est pas mal et s'excuse pas du
tout t'excuses pas du tout genre non
parce que s'ils en sont arrivés là
il voulait voir ça je préfère prévient
jeudi
bon voila j'ai pensé à vous je vais
c'est pour ça que j'ai fait la vidéo au
début du 2 j'avais expliqué que georges
fait des contenus ou genre ya beaucoup
de trucs hyper c'est hyper scripté et
tous genres les coups de fil les salles
au sli c'était un truc même les popotes
un peu et que j'en ris il faut
s'attendre à justin moment venu pourquoi
tu vois en quoi tu te poser tous les
jeunes de toronto
ouais elle avait au final quelle belle
conclusion
c'est un slf